I love,
you know,
like I have certain favorite fighters of course a Donald Serani.
I love Nick Diaz for them.
Um,
but uh,
Jorge Mazda though he's a beast.
I just love,
I love like just a true fighter and he's so good.
So good.
He's so fucking good and so smart.
Oh,
you're so smart man.
Clever changes it up.
Does things like you can't see what he's doing.
Subtle.
He lives for fighting to Ah,
really does.
Oh,
he's a fucking smart man.
Like there are men and then there's hearts hand outs.
Mosquito just shows on another level for sure.
He's on another level.
He's,
I think he's such a contender for,
I mean he just chewed here.
The a hundred percent of the content was less than a cowboy and it takes two
years out of the octagon.
I don't know what,
he must have had an injury.
Darren till knocked out Darren till,
I mean knocked him the fuck out.
I mean he hit him with that left hand a couple of times early in the fight too.
He was doing some sneaky shit.
He was switching stances.
He was switching stances and throwing that left hand.
Yeah,
he was throwing the right hand switching stances,
throwing the left hand and I think he started to read till pulling back like
that and then faked.
He finally through that right and then,
oh,
he left.
He'd caught him with that left hand several times,
caught him in the first round and then caught him in the second round.
He's a,
he's a bad motherfucker man.
He really is.
He's coming on to and I'm going to have mom with Joey d is Mom's all is going to
come up with show ideas and get a little bit,
you may also be able to get knocked down like that by Darren.
Tell who hits like it,
you know,
and come back and just regain his composure.
Never tell them the first punch of the fight.
It was the first punch of the fight now and smile to any ads.
All right,
let's see what you did first.
Move the fight.
He charges towards till and tries to side kick him in the thigh and hits him in
the Dick.
Yeah,
like right away.
First shot right to the SAC.
Yep.
Yeah.
I love that guy.
I love,
I love watching him fight.
Well,
he's very crafty.
He's a real veteran.
You know,
I remember him knocking out,
uh,
Eve Edwards in Bodog fight.